hey welcome back this is John de Loney
my good for an FeO Neal we're saving the
world and um we just if you watch the
last video we figured out quantum
physics and stuff like that and so we're
onto the next thing
and that is this we're talking about
life after crazy we've talked about what
we found about ourselves we didn't like
about being lonely here's the big
question
what are you gonna do right now to begin
your new path forward everyone keep talk
about new normal you know I'm gonna like
new normal yeah yeah like we got to find
some stuff out about ourselves right
yeah you know so when I think about the
two main things that I really learned
over this which was my lack of patience
and me being lonely the very first thing
is I'm really going to dive deep and
creating a true community so I have good
friends I have relatives and mentors
outside of Nashville but I just joined
the local church here recently within
the last four months and so I'm really
gonna get involved in that community I
established a level of accountability
with my spiritual pastor and just also
start joining some small groups and
build true friendships relationships
mentors ships here locally in Nashville
which that will then even help me with
my lack of patience because if I'm
surrounding myself with healthy
individuals they will hold me
accountable to how I'm thinking and
processing things and teach me really
not really teach me but hold me
accountable when it comes to just really
being patient understanding loving I
mean caring you just said something
heavy and you are an expert working with
Millennials and their parents yeah we so
often live our lives everywhere but what
we're we're but where we actually are so
we like give me some tactics like I know
okay I'm gonna small groups to it like
what are you gonna do okay you start
calling people like I'm gonna schedule
like we will meet for happy hour this
many times a week like what is that
gonna look like I'm gonna babysit your
kid like what does that mean so one of
the things I've actually started doing
Wow
towards the end of
quarantine time was I actually called my
pastor at least once a week okay and
actually had a real conversation and and
opened up to him like he was my
counselor my therapist I was like hey
this is what's in my head this is what's
going on and then I was shut up and
allowed him to talk into my life Anthony
you're doing this room you're thinking
about this wrong hey we need to actually
pray about this situation we need to
pray about this thought and it's
refreshing so many people myself
included we find ourselves lonely and we
look around and blame everybody else
they won't accept me they don't like me
they told me that I look like this or I
smell like that you just said something
important that if we're gonna have to a
community we got to go first yeah I got
to take the risk of being vulnerable
your pastor could have climbed on you
mean like don't you work for Dave Ramsey
don't you not right and it hurt too I
was like okay I was like whoa what am i
doing but so when I got over that hump
it was like man it's actually it was
refreshing
I felt something get off of my shoulder
and be like yo I needed that because you
know we're personalities people are
coming to us all the time asking us for
advice asking us for help and and I have
family and friends on the outside but
now once we get out of this quarantine
situation we're gonna skip a phone call
and when I'm in town we're gonna go get
breakfast we're gonna get some face time
together to where we can just really
talk as as a as a man to a younger man
and just get some wisdom David Kessler
says you can go through life with no
pain you can you can choose that but
that means you'll have no relationships
you'll have no love you have no
community and you'll probably die young
and pretty sick I don't want that life
so what you just said is the key right
is to be connected and not be lonely
means you're going to put yourself out
there be vulnerable you have to be
willing to risk someone saying hey I'll
go to breakfast I'm not going to write
this I'm not getting up and you having
to feel that pain but that's worth it to
be connected it's to be whole hey you
know what I even say here I have never
said this on my show I like you
doing this with my pastor is actually
gonna
help me be prepared to be vulnerable
with my future spouse because I went
through an engagement and got out of it
and I've been scared to be vulnerable
hmm you know and so now having this
conversation with him it's just been
like I can be I can be vulnerable and
it's okay to be vulnerable because it
just feels good so I'm looking forward
to that
normally I've got some fancy thing to
say because we've we're in this together
now and you realize how smart and genius
I am I guess I thought that after that
that was awesome this is John to Loney
my good friend Anthony O'Neill we'll be
back with one more of these and it's
about to get really good clicks and
subscribes help him out he needs a few
more subscribers so if you want to go to
his show tell him where you're at
and Maddie can go to youtube for size
Anthony O'Neill I'm there I don't need a
lot he needs a lot more trust me
see you soon take care